nous voici chez plan ap dans le
vieux-montréal connu pour son
comparateur de forfaits cellulaires à la
demande de l'émission la facture
l'entreprise a concocté un questionnaire
qui détermine les véritables besoins des
abonnés à internet et les compagnies
sont là pour faire des sous sont les
entreprises et les consommateurs eux en
revanche d'affaires doivent faire leur
travail de clients saisir enfin en train
de comparaison de bien connaître le
besoin de faire un travail de magasinage
pour répondre au questionnaire guy
gerbal qui pèse 70 dollars par mois pour
son internet
son forfait illimité lui offre une
vitesse ultra rapide de 4 100 mégabits
seconde
c'est ce qui explique en partie sa
mensualité élevés comme c'est un peu
langue temps en temps je me dis belge
c'est comme ça que j'étais toujours vers
un peu plus haut on accède au
questionnaire en allant sur la page club
point ca est en cliquant sur l'onglet
internet
huit questions apparaissent à l'écran à
quelle fréquence de ménage télécharge
t-il des fichiers volumineux 9
je suis jamais l'évaluateur de plan
conclu que monsieur gerbal n'a besoin
que de 28 mégabits seconde et on lui
suggère une liste de fournisseurs du
plus abordables ou plus cher mais
comment les petits fournisseurs peuvent
se l'offrir des tarifs moins élevés tout
en restant fiable je veux savoir c'est
que les fonds ne soient indépendants
vont louer de l'espace sur les lèvres
structure des gros joueurs et donc ils
utilisent les mêmes réseaux là leur
service et peu moins fiables exactement
les mêmes câbles qui sont utilisés au
final parmi les gros joueurs
vidéotron précise que les petits sont
des revendeurs d'internet que nos pas à
maintenir et améliorer leurs réseaux
quant à guy gerbal club lui propose un
petit fournisseur qui lui ferait
économiser 39 dollars par mois
j'ai mal dormi cette nuit à cause de
vous parce que je vais dire mon dieu
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire avec
l'argent que je peux économiser
éventuellement sa facture mensuelle
passerait donc de 70 à 31 dollars
ici yves lamontagne radio-canada mourir